you want me to eat all of these chicken
wings and not cry it can't be done hey
what's going on everybody four first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and this is the hot
ones reunion special brought to you by
Corona Extra it's the reunion special
attack questions and even hotter wings
and today we're reunited with Jay
Pharoah what's up people you know him
from his six seasons on Saturday Night
Live he has a music project heartbreak
on the way a stand-up comedian actor and
musician not to mention illustrious hot
ones guest Jay Pharoah it feels good to
see you in the seat here it does it
feels good to be in the hot seat again
that is not hot because I handle it what
is it like seeing hot ones fans in the
wild do people ever stop you on the
street to talk about your date with the
wings of death yes yes they do
yes a dougie I get the run up on me and
they'll say a man I believe if you like
hot ones and I'm like okay I have done
other stuff they're like yeah man you
had but come on it wasn't hot was though
you killed it so yo yo yo the love of me
getting it's crazy well it's time to
build on that legacy a little bit Jay
are you ready I am ready
[Music]
and you know the drill see ya oh that's
a nice tease have some nice T's right
there that's like a footer you know I'm
saying she's using a foot not doing
anything else
so wanna start by taking it back to
before the days of Hollywood back when
you worked at a Golden Corral
oh hell is there a restaurant trade
secret you know something that you've
seen behind the scenes that makes you
weary whenever you dine out now
yes sending food back sending food we
gotta be careful with that I've got to
be careful well of course I was that
Golden Corral so I didn't know I didn't
see a lot of food sent back around ever
my dad used to work in the food industry
you know I mean so you know he said
never send anything back
even though contradictory with his
actions he is one of the most most rude
people in restaurants it's so fun and I
don't think he knows he does it
sometimes but like we're at Carrabba's
and they sent this pasta dish he eats it
he goes it's just not how I remember it
tasted the lady was like I'm sorry to go
it's just not happy I was like did you
just slam your hands on the table I was
like oh he's fitting to get lit up in
here but I was happy because I already
had my food so I said yeah you can go
ahead and talk our trash you want to I'm
enjoying my spit free meal
Salzburg usually saw mm-hmm good so I
know that you're an extremely proficient
MC in your own right but you're also a
student of the game I know that you
study the Titans like jay-z Big Al Xie
Luda
Big L I can't do I don't know I'm never
trying what I want to do is bounce some
of the craziest headlines going on in
hip hop right now I'm just curious where
Jay Pharoah where he lies okay cool
would you make of this story about blue
face having sex with over a thousand
women in the last six months lot work
there's a lot of work yeah maybe maybe
7680 but a thousand come on now and I
and then I don't even want to think
about blue face having intercourse
because it sounds with come on [ __ ]
give me love it like you know you
sitting you're screaming the whole time
hey don't beat with it I don't get it
right I don't get it I don't think he
did it I don't get it I don't think
there's that many deaf women that will
allow him to smash mo Bamba top ten rap
song of the decade or not top ten reps
on the decade oh you know it's really
weird were you in there in a car full of
white people and they're singing every
lyric and you're just looking around
like well you better be glad I want to
smash you girl cuz your girl shouldn't
be saying this [ __ ] it crossing some
line crossing some damn lines do I think
it's one of the top ten I think is it's
one of the top ten lit song see you go
there you go can I say that you can say
that lyrical but lit lit lit not that L
that I'm saying
but you will push a quando on a piece of
chicken I'm so offended it's between a
tough spot it puts me in a tough spot
because we're friends because we're
friends we have so much we have so much
chemistry I'm gonna go ahead let that
bypass and try to eat this way I
appreciate that so I know that you
started rapping at 13 and that comedy at
15
how does bombing on stage when you're
rapping compared to bombing on stage as
a comedian like have you ever had some
sort of eight-mile moment yeah how dude
it's 2009 Elizabeth City is a freaking
step show worse than you can have being
a comedian is a litte Dance Crew
why you gotta tell jokes you know why
why because their energy does not match
your [ __ ] right so whatever you try to
do after they come on stage your
performance is trash and eventually I
said some wack and then the girl stood
up she was like she was doing I said sit
your big ass down looking like a goddang
tree out this [ __ ] I didn't know what
else to say in shadow green total vision
like a tree play what I was so nervous
but I battle with that crown for like
five minutes and they shut up there you
go so I wouldn't I think Bill Bird did
it bill burr beat the whole Philadelphia
Eagles say yeah that's a [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] he said yeah
your statue of Rocky is not even real
[ __ ] you and your Philly cheesesteaks
[ __ ] you
then I was like there yo yo [ __ ] y'all
with your Lizbeth city and your slow
driving and you [ __ ] shower caps with
you shower caps with your rollers in
your hair with your holes in your
sweatpants going to Burlington
getting your layaway off I know cuz I'm
the person you come see I was saying
Hobert [ __ ] but i won boom i won baby
just like bill birnes what it is what it
do baby koala
I like to leave my corpses up there I
know I like that might kill mugger wins
is this your wing is this your wing no
I'm the king now okay still the king see
mm-hmm I hit me back here hit you back
here in the back of your tongue right
there in that taste blood that's right
there a little bit so last time you and
I were walking through the wings of
death we had unexpected guests that
included DMX Denzel Washington and Eddie
Murphy so this time around we want to
give fans a taste at some of our most
requested white whale guests okay sure
Keanu Reeves how are you at spicy food
these wings are so spicy but it's okay
because I can take them but going to the
end it can't be done you want me to eat
all of these chicken wings and not cry
it can't be done you put any wing in
front of me and I'm just gonna let you
know I'm gonna kill that wing because
that's what I do
Kanye West it looks like you have
something you gotta get off your chest
you know um uh you know because um you
know I just want to say this about the
wings you know I have children now Sean
okay late last time I was here you know
I might have had half a baby you know I
just I just gotta be careful with my
bowels fam you know because you know my
kids see you know if they see me running
to the bathroom and they smell it you
know they always go ahead an image
are they dad hey so you know um you know
maybe capture share these wings with me
Nick Cage do you have a favorite hot
sauce well my favorite hot sauce
definitely would be the most extreme sir
I think the last dab would be my
favorite because I go to the extremes
with my acting sir I think this wing
right here definitely would be my baby
idris elba we were so excited to have
you on the show last season where Jason
Statham and the rock impressed with your
performance well you know when it comes
down to you know chasing two-way Johnson
uh those guys are [ __ ] you know so I
really don't talk to them a lot you know
we did it singing together you know it
was cool and everything but you know
those guys pretty much have like you
know hit points that they do on stage me
I don't care while I'm sexy you know
we'll just made everyone looking at me
pregnant
[Music]
Wow
tastes like ramen noodles i J we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham where we do a deep
dive on our guests Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context I wish I wish I wouldn't have
archived so much on my shoe
well we got some good ones good all
right so here you are with Denzel
Washington
yep that's at the AFI Lifetime
Achievement Awards and um I walked up to
him I was a a I don't know if you know
Jaime sir oh snap I know you are negro
yeah you owe me money you know whatever
you owe me a lot of money and the way he
said it I was like yo Joey right I do a
lot of money because I have made a lot
of cake from doing the in president and
I'm like [ __ ] so it was so dough we had
this moment as we're talking they flash
a picture and we both stopped and posed
for the camera so this that happened so
say but I'm gonna call pitching where
you gonna pitch you do your pose face
sure all right so I was like this
cuz I can't man so yeah man so anyway so
um yeah bro I appreciate your work I
love your picture
yeah man it's like that was the sweetie
should ever and Chris Tucker's behind so
Chris Tucker immediately grabs his that
is a man this is gonna take a picture my
son man right here man I'm like yo man I
wanted to get a picture for myself so
they take the picture together and then
Denzel go to sit down and I would say
Chris man you messed myself cause I
wanted to take a picture he said man go
ahead over there man go ask a man he
gonna take a picture with you man
just don't let him get too comfortable
yeah soon as he gettin older but
something like that you know hang over
you taking a picture right now he got on
his head he just sat down so I walk over
there I said mr. Washington
can I please take a picture with you
heõs yeah you can take a picture if
you've been lean down can you lean down
can you lean can you drop a like his hot
if you can drop it now we're definitely
didn't say drop like I but he said you
can lean that I'll take this picture
with you
I said I'll bend down ain't gonna bend
over but I will bend down for you miss
watch on a bent down we took that
picture and I was quiet and I was so
happy with my Eddie Murphy smile it's a
great picture yeah he doesn't look too
amused
I did my Shaquille o Neal impression
with Kenny the jet Smith and Charles
Barkley
it was so funny Kenny was like can you
do it in Charles Barker's like yo man
that's crazy you're gonna do it so I so
I did the impression and there's no
there's no freaking lines but it didn't
matter you know why cuz I my eyes across
I can't read anything anyway so when I
was on SNL and I would do that character
I would have to like flash take a
picture of my mind of what was being
said and then when it was my turn to
talk like Kenan would like hit me like
this and I would I would go cuz you
didn't have a safety net no I don't have
a safety net and I can't I can't see the
lines you know I mean so on this one
yeah I freestyle the whole thing are
like my troops what to do
I love dudes awesome okay so it's all
good awful Shaq it's amazing love chef
chuckle love it love it and I did that
and it went over one over great and Shaq
like it yeah you're black
fly low enough people tell them I'll
keep doing keep doing
we like the owner Shack keep no on a
Shack don't stop doing them so arias no
I think it's really funny it's really
funny
you're funny you're really funny you're
very funny very funny guy very you funny
you can't kick you know why you're the
[ __ ] chair you're gonna chair you
can't use your legs you can't kick [ __ ]
so that's such a lovely segue because
we'd be remiss not to mention that
you're one of if not the best
impressionist of our time what are the
mechanics of a great comedic impression
like it seems like there's this
immediate off actor where you're like oh
that's recognizable I know that but then
there's something that yeah that you
change to make the joke last okay first
you want a voice that you want a voice
that everybody knows but not necessarily
knows that's the first key to it
second is taking those parts of of their
character and exaggerating them fully
like you know what you do you know oh
you do little baby man man man guys
hopefully I'll do way how do you know
you just take that hang in hang it just
have them playing a banjo Oh taro like
this you know upset so you take the
little bit you just exaggerated oh no
that's crazy
wait wait wait [ __ ] I'm the baby okay
any no I heard oh and your show white
famous one of the gags is that you'll
use Denzel Washington's voice as a way
to you know more attractive ladies I do
that I do that really that sounds gonna
ask have you ever used voices for good
or for evil in your real life
like I'll walk around my house and [ __ ]
like okay y'all get the walk is fine get
the walk so I walk around my house and
[ __ ] like this must be looking I'll be
passive I'm be you know certain I just
I'll just walk I'll look up you don't
know what I'm doing yet yeah I'll look
up
[Music]
that's fight is dead my [ __ ] is it true
that Matt Damon is the one who put you
on Steven Soderbergh's yep hey now it
was Matt Damon who's Matt Damon shout
out to Matt Damon shout out to Matt
Damon shut off the Steven Soderbergh cuz
I know where you're gonna segue to
because we're like this I mean yeah yeah
but shared they won a set it might have
been aa shion's Matt Damon was like I
can't do all that damn he was like dude
you gotta see this gotta see his
impressions Stevens not a bad Matt Damon
forever thank you got to see this
impression you got to see it and then
Steven Soderbergh was like oh he's good
he's real good and then I got insane
because he wanted to show my dramatic
chops at a twirl
yep we're right here man right here we
forget we write a mess aim paddleboat
down the hot sauce room we're in a
gondola me and the gondola that's right
we ain't doing freaky [ __ ] we're just
riding but we in the gondola together
you're doing that
I drink hot sauce which is crazy I used
to drink it when I was a fat kid and I
was in church we had this kitchen right
it was a kitchen now says it was like
seven teen hot sauce bottles I drank all
of them and at the time you probably
didn't think you know at one point this
will really allow me to shine on a
youtube talk show that features chicken
wings did not know that crazy like what
I didn't know but I did know Sean is
that I'll never drink 17 bottles of hot
sauce again says we touched on your last
interview uh-huh you're a committed gym
rat and it's clear that in the time
sense you have not been skipping any
reps no no I have not
dude come on man put it up try it you
got it I am trying not like that I'm
just trying to get thrown I'm just
trying to get thrown by the Wayne
Johnson in one of these movies The Rock
says the Ross gonna throw you to brownie
but you really get thrown is [ __ ] I'm
ready man I'm the topic of ripped
comedians okay who wins in an I quit
match between you Bryan Callen and Kevin
Hart oh I'm whooping all the ass I'll
let him have [ __ ] up Kevin Hart Kent
Kevin Hart Bryan Callen I'm sorry Bryan
soul ding well he's older he'll mess
with me he was whoosing ride along this
cuz you're a ride along don't mean [ __ ]
brother I wasn't ride alone - I got
thrown by his Q means 5 foot 9 all right
it really wasn't really an effect me so
you put all three of us in a ring I'm
gonna frickin win now Kevin he gonna
keep trying to get back in but you know
what just you just hold keV like this he
ain't that hate that big chronic
allocate [ __ ] with me but he's in good
shape he's in good shape yeah man Chris
D'Elia will well 3 will 3d Dudley bomb
that [ __ ]
[Music]
just a little spicy
[Applause]
oh this is the one who's trying to take
care of the taste away
[Music]
max girlfriend trying to do that it
didn't work is it true that you once saw
Robin Williams rapping uh Swizz Beatz on
yep
oh [ __ ] ridiculous oh yes I can't
believe oh [ __ ] ridiculous
oh that's all he did
your music it's so clearly like your
comedy and extension of your personality
when you have a thought is there sort of
like a mechanism something that triggers
when you're like this would be a better
verse or this would be a better joke um
what I used to do sorry
got a little damnation on my um on the
top of my um nice it yo your cheeks are
sweating listen we're SHINee over here
are we SHINee
we're SHINee we're shining it up real
nice
so what I used to do my freestyle I used
to take like quotables I always make
hooks out of it
I just think about it jot it down right
around it and then somehow for my dope
hook I see you and I see yeah it's a
little bit are we ready to move on down
the line just do it alright so this is
the chocolate plague from Parker but
[Music]
you don't know you know what a a couple
times the season I caught my eye and
that's the worst [ __ ] ever so now I'm
like super like I'm super careful about
it in a way that's absurd
like I'll have to like hear my eye I'm
like the shoulder of my shirt and then
be like all right you ready I'm ready
[Music]
so we've talked what's the question shot
we've talked today about how you just
want to get thrown by the rock I know
that you've made a many a pitch to be in
black panther - why not
got the rest of the black people in
there why not put my ass in there come
on come on it's me come on you got all
those people in there bro
I think me Craig Robinson and Chris Rock
all need to be in a condom condom I mean
come on man come over I thought it's
gonna be way hotter it's nice here
there's my rapper chick shoutout
magda stallion how you doing big old
freak yeah i watch your stuff I'm
infatuated like all your videos you are
a stallion it's a hot girl summer that's
right
that's why they give my number to a
chick I told it was a hot crew so cuz
ya'll hot out here
ok back to this well speaking of hot is
this the last one
[Music]
are you not entertained dip - it a
little dip a little soak you ready I'm
ready
but I run it's been Jay
hi Jay Pharaoh here we are at the end of
our run your second ascent to the top of
mount Scoville in a moment a BTS moment
of hot ones that we talk about all the
time is after the cameras cut last time
you just did a Cassidy verse for about
four straight minutes
must have been 48 bars so here we
thought it was only right now that we
have the cameras actually rolling how
are you feeling after 10 scorching hot
chicken wings I'd have finished the
challenge my nose running but I got to
the end without being a [ __ ] so that's
the hunted you see of it they watching
me or hot ones they love it see I'm the
person that comes on the show the type
of black celebrity they covet you see
it's different baby because my blood
type was say and now it's really shady
and you gotta say call Kb
see I'm on a V that's an accelerated
view now understand I ate the chicken so
to all the clucks out there in the
chicken heads I will say [ __ ] you you
don't get it see I'm battle rapping and
crapping see after this affirmative
action I don't know what I'm crapping
but I'm probably gonna need some toilet
tissue to get all the action you get
what I'm saying but I killed the
challenge I did it and I ate these wings
chickens see me now they'd be like don't
mess with them cuz that dude do a lot of
violence you see Shaun I am hot once
that's my blood type you need wet wipes
not me
all hype JP all-night ride tight and
look y'all ain't even close you see I
thought to kill this challenge see I'm
gonna take your chick and probably spear
it like the Holy Ghost shoot know what
I'm saying
it's bars up in here I'm Lars up in here
it won't hard up in here because I'm
hard right here you get it check out the
tongue I got the tongue
Oh God salute yes baby spit by your
straight fire and look at you Jay
Pharoah second time and the wings of
death and killed it in front of the
blacks and vanilla shuttle get hold illa
twenty chicken wings Arnie 20 chicken
wings down and one more for good measure
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you Jay Pharoah
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you got going on in
your life Hey look I'm filming this
movie right now just Casablanca Records
biopic called spin and gold baby uh-huh
I'm playing Cecil homes and I got this
project I'm bout to drop called
heartbreak y'all make sure y'all check
that [ __ ] out bars Jay Pharoah baby my
best friend one of my best colonies
Shawn
Charlotte [ __ ] if he's [ __ ]
Heathcote piece of girl get him a beer
he's the coke Jimmy this hot sauce look
at this head you'll get a hot you'll get
a nail
you'll get a nail y'all get ales cuz i
prevail hey hey hey yes it was so much
fun it was so fair thank you baby I got
some [ __ ] on my ass hey what's going on
hot ones fans this is Sean Evans
checking in to say thank you so much for
watching our reunion special with Jay
Pharoah season 10 it is just around the
corner so hold on to your seats it's
coming it's coming fast in the meantime
if you missed let's say Andrew Ray's
episode where you got a tattoo while
eating the wings of death you can check
that out here or of course our season 9
finale with Stone Cold Steve Austin and
when you hear season 9 finale you know
season 10 premiere is on its heels we'll
see you soon baby
[Music]